[Music]
it's twitches too spelled with two O's
because clever if you saw my review of
the first film you know that I thought
it was actually kind of well done
yeah for what it is it's a good family
fantasy that has some good laughs and
legitimately good drama and some magical
elements the sequel is pretty much the
same not in the bad way like everything
is on repeat they do throw in a lot of
new stuff heck they actually take out a
lot of the annoying things from the
first one like they very rarely say gute
twitches or do any catchphrases
in fact I can only think of two at the
end where they do that stupid little
dance and then they both go loser oh
that's painful the rest of the film is
once again kind of cheesy but kind of
interesting to our twitches played again
by the Maori sisters find that being
friends is one thing but being sisters
living together is something different
they're sniffing at each other more
having disagreements and not always
getting along but at the end of the day
they're still sisters and they still
connect but that comes to a bit of a
head when their mother the real mother
reveals that another evil force is
slowly slipping into their Kingdom and
they need their magic to stop it
particularly during an eclipse it seems
that someone or something in the shadow
world is trying to infiltrate their real
world their magic can get rid of it for
good but there's one problem while most
of the people think it's Thanos the
villain from the first film one of the
sisters thinks it's her father
and because we don't see things from the
point of view of the shadowy monster it
very well could be this creates a rift
between the sisters as well as the rest
of the family including their bickering
protectors who have now decided to get
married all throughout the film metrical
Clues backstories shadow sneaking around
all indicate that something is up but we
don't quite know what is it the villain
is it the father even if it is the
father look at this portrait Finn maybe
he's a bad guy too after all they were
related the pacing and atmosphere in
this movie is still reasonably well done
so many times you'll just see a shadow
sneaking in the background you have no
idea is this for good or for evil and
this creates a nice family dynamic among
our heroes in fact there's even more
than that they find out that not
everybody can use magic in fact is
practically outlawed well the mother
sees this as a necessity while the
sisters doesn't and both sides have very
legitimate point
it's not something like Little Mermaid 3
where Allmusic is outlawed and that's
obviously bad here it actually kind of
makes sense the choices that people make
and the arguments they have for their
side again I feel like that strangely
the strength of these movies is that
there actually is kind of a family
connection disagreements don't always
mean one is obviously right and one is
obviously wrong but on top of that
there's a ton of other things that
Disney Channel viewers would like you
get to see him go on date you find that
one might be a prince but that turns out
he's just wearing a butler's outfit
because he works in the kitchen there's
a boyfriend who used to date one of the
sisters and now he's dating the other
one but this shadow suddenly possesses
him maybe it seems to be following him
there's all sorts of nice little touches
going on the effects are still pretty
bad but they're at least a little better
than the last one
they at least try to go more cinematic
with them sometimes they work other
times they're pretty awkward but
thankfully a lot of it is shot more
cinematically so you're more looking at
the nice sets and cinematography than
you are how bad the effects are yeah for
the most part again they can't be really
awkward it's funny because I just had to
watch return to Halloweentown where a
lot of it obviously steals from Harry
Potter here this one steals from Harry
Potter too but it also kind of steals
from Laurie the Rings with shadowy
figures and even a ring and a dark
presence trying to take human form and
yeah on the one hand I could shout rip
off it does seem to come back to its own
thing just enough and the elements it
does borrow from Harry Potter and Laura
the ring seemed to be good elements that
they're borrowing from like there's a
back story about how the mother and
father met the father want to get the
mother a gift and so she has for a star
and that's exactly what he got her a
star that can fit in her pocket that
seems Harry Potter asked but it's just
different enough to let it pass that
dark presence you always feel watching
you and always seems to be around very
much feels like Sauron for Laura the
Rings but again they add that you don't
know if it's evil and you don't know
what it can do it's almost like it's
similar ideas but the changes they make
are just enough to make it so it's not
really distracting and you're still
invested in the story add some good
one-liners and even some good dramatic
moments yeah
yeah the sequel about as good as the
first one it still has hammered in
moments and schmaltzy moments but again
I think that's kind of expected for a
Disney Channel movie when it wants to
get a small laugh out of you it works
and when it wants to get a little
emotion out of you it works then - I'm
actually Kant surprised I like these
movies as much as I did I doubt I'll
play it again but that's called I sit
down and watch them once it felt like
there was a lot more to it than just
Sister Sister if they were witches it
has its own universe it has its own
identity and it has more than enough to
keep kids entertained I know it's weird
but as these Disney Channel movies go
these films are surprisingly pretty
decent
[Music]